Facebook and Instagram's parent company
matters launching a new app that could
rival Twitter the threads app will
launch on Thursday it will allow
Instagram users to write posts while
keeping their accounts and followers on
Saturday the head of Twitter Elon Musk
restricted the number of tweets users
could see must bought Twitter last year
for 44 billion dollars and has
introduced a number of changes
well musk responded to the news of a new
arrival to his company by tweeting thank
goodness they're so sanely run he took a
jab at meta topics top executive Chris
Cox last month Cox said users have been
asking for a platform that is sanely run
and is reliable
well Drew benvey is from Baton Hall a
social media Communications agency he
explained why change that Twitter are
creating opportunities for other social
media companies
this is perfect timing for meta because
other social networks had actually been
benefiting from Twitter's turmoil in
recent uh days and in recent weeks and
months every time there's an outage
every time there's a policy change or
safety moderators are let go of Twitter
uh people start voting with their
fingers and starting to use other social
networks that emulate Twitter and as yet
there hasn't been a high profile one
which is why meta is launching threads
now we use many social networks and we
usually look for a few things safety uh
free use in return for some advertising
for the advertising to be appropriate
and none of that seems to be happening
at Twitter of late Elon Musk seemed to
in the beginning want to cut costs and
he did this by letting staff go
um what happened then was the experience
degraded then advertisers left and now
most recently he seems to be trying to
make money through selling user
subscriptions which is this Twitter blue
and the response to Twitter going down
over the weekend was to limit the use of
Twitter to non-paying users therefore
trying to I don't know if it's making
money more important than stabilizing
the service but neither seem to be
working so I think his strategy is a bit
too conflicted to be useful